- Good morning and welcome to the STARS
25th Anniversary Celebration.
My name is Sandy Chang,
Associate Dean of STEM
Education at Yale college
and Director of the STARS Program.
I'll be moderating today's sessions.
We gathered to celebrate
STARS for the first time
since its inception.
By any measure,
STARS has been extraordinarily successful.
Women and underrepresented
students participated in STARS,
are significantly more likely
to persist in STEM majors
and to pursue STEM
disciplines after graduation.
We were here
for some of these extraordinary
STARS alums today.
Students will also get to meet them
in the breakout sessions later on.
We'll also hear from some of the leaders
who made the STARS Program possible.
Many of these individuals
continue to serve this program today,
a testament to their dedication
to make Yale STEM more
inclusive and equitable.
President Peter Salovey,
the Chris Argyris Professor of Psychology,
will lead off the program
with a short video.
- Hello!
I'm Peter Salovey,
President of Yale university.
Thank you for inviting me
to join you to celebrate
the 25th anniversary of STARS.
A quarter century ago,
Professor Kurt Zilm,
and university secretary
and vice president for
university life, Kim Goff-Crews,
recognized the need for
a program like this.
Thanks to their vision,
hundreds of Yale students have gained
firsthand research experience and support
for navigating their majors
and building careers.
Women and others from
underrepresented groups in science
have received the mentorship
and opportunities we know
are essential for success in STEM fields.
I also want to express my
appreciation to Dean Sandy Chang
for leading STARS with such
enthusiasm and dedication.
Many faculty members have
been critical partners
in this work.
They've taught courses
and served as role models.
Research shows that role
models play a powerful role
particularly for students
who come from backgrounds
that aren't well-represented in sciences.
Accomplished educators
and researchers at YALE
like Dean Chang,
Dean Marvin Chun,
Professor Zilm and professor McGarry
have inspired students
through this program.
The rewards have been great.
STARS alumni have gone on to build careers
and make contributions to
science, technology and medicine.
At Yale, welcoming students and scholars
from diverse backgrounds is
a university-wide priority.
We know diversity is
integral to excellence,
fueling discovery and answering
our most urgent questions.
As you know,
based on engagement from
every part of our community,
I launched programs that
are part of the next phase
of the belonging at Yale initiative.
These programs dive into our history,
assess and build on our current actions,
support members of the
university community
and create a stronger Yale for the future.
They help us to continue to lead the way
in teaching and research
of the highest caliber.
As we collaborate on this vital work,
it is especially important to foster
a sense of belonging
and inclusion in STEM.
We've made progress in
increasing representation
from diverse groups in these fields,
but there is more to do.
We know that our students today
are the leaders and the
mentors of tomorrow.
And so programs like STARS are essential
to fulfilling Yale's mission
to improve the world today
and for future generations.
Thank you to everyone
who has made this program
such a success,
and congratulations on
this wonderful milestone.
I look forward to the next
25 years of STARS at Yale.
- Thank you very much President Salovey.
Our next speaker is Marvin
Chun, Dean of Yale college,
the Richard and Colgate
Professor of Psychology
and Professor of Neuroscience.
Dean Chun.
- Good morning everyone.
It's such an exciting day
to be here for the 25th
anniversary of STARS.
It is absolutely a top
priority for Yale College,
and as a scientist leading
a brain imaging lab,
I'm showing our brain scanner behind me,
it's a program that's
very dear to my heart.
As you just heard STARS really exemplifies
President Salovey's mission for Yale,
to be their research
university most committed
to teaching and learning.
And we're also really grateful
to university secretary
and vice president for
student life, Kim Goff-Crews,
who not only, you know,
who leads our diversity, equity, inclusion
and belonging initiatives,
that is a major priority for Yale.
I really celebrate her for
founding this STARS Program
along with Professor Kurt Zilm
and Professor Kenneth Nelson.
And I also, you know,
I'm grateful for this opportunity to thank
and to recognize Dr. Sandy
Chan, Professor Sandy Chang.
He is truly passionate and tireless
in his leadership of STARS.
He thinks about STARS all the time
and you really cannot ask
for a better colleague,
a better associate Dean of Science
and quantitative reasoning education.
You know, as an accomplished MD, PhD,
clinician and scientist himself,
and as a Yale alum, a Yale college alum,
I think he really embodies
what we're trying to
achieve with this program
even as he says one of his motivations
for leading this program
is that he did not get to benefit
from something like this himself.
I really also wanna thank
our fabulous colleagues
and faculty for teaching in this program
and for mentoring students in your labs.
You know you are the engine
that really make this possible
and make it successful.
And of course I applaud the students.
Many of you who are here as alumni,
again serving as role models,
but it's really your
engagement with the program.
You know, you're giving
your best is what allows us,
which has kept this program
strong for 25 years.
You know in this program
you've demonstrated dedication,
persistence and resilience.
You know, science is hard,
it has a lot of setbacks
but your ability to overcome
these challenges, bad data,
just, you know, hard to long days,
you know, it's what you've
demonstrated in the labs
that again has made this
program so successful.
And, you know, nothing makes me happier
than to see our students, you know,
thrive through this program
and to have good rewards after graduation,
good careers after graduation
based on the experiences that
you've gained through STARS.
And so dean I'm grateful
for this opportunity
to thank you all,
and I wanna just close by saying
that it's absolutely a top goal for me
to expand this program
so that every student
who wants to participate
can benefit from it.
And so I really hope even as
soon as the 30th anniversary
and ideally even sooner,
I or my successor will be able to say
that this program is fully funded.
So, but today I look forward
to celebrating this milestone
with you all,
and I thank you all for being here.
Have a good day.
- Thank you so much Marvin Chun,
and thank you for your
continued support for Yale STEM.
Our next speaker is Kim Goff-Crews,
the secretary and vice
president for university life.
Secretary Crews.
- Thank you Dr. Chang.
First of all, I am so excited to be here,
I'm honored to be here
to celebrate with you
this milestone in STARS history.
I, as people mentioned was there
at the very, very beginning,
and I'm surprised and grateful
that it has lasted as long as it has,
I wasn't sure that it would.
Professor Zilm and I were
part of a small team of...
And Dr. Nelson also, a small
team of faculty and staff
that were looking to grow a program
particularly for students
of color and women
that would ensure that they
could persist in the sciences.
And it's interesting because
it's succeeded a program
that was called AMPS.
It was called the
Academic Mentoring Program
in the Sciences.
That wasn't really working as well.
So we took a year off
to actually figure out
what we wanted to do.
And most people don't know this,
that before STARS there was nothing,
it was a year of nothing,
and then we actually went
on a little bit of a tour
and doing some research around the country
to figure out what we
might do differently.
And with that wonderful team
of Ken Nelson, back to Zilm,
Iona Black came in just at the right time,
and Kayla's came in a little later.
We began to, actually the faculty
began to develop a program
that they thought was really
worthy of the students,
but they wanted to provide service for.
They had four but main themes
that they were really focusing on
as they were building the program.
One is, we were all focused
on following the students,
particularly that initial student group,
what their needs were,
and so STARS I was the
first iteration of STARS,
then STARS Summer,
because the students were
gonna go into summer program,
then STARS II because then
the students were becoming,
you know, becoming sophomores and juniors
so we followed the students.
We were very focused on
focusing on the whole student
and not just their academic work.
And we were very focused on
having very high expectations
but also creating community
and not competition.
And so you'll see those things, I think,
have really gone through
STARS for the last 25 years
with this wonderful group
of faculty and staff
who have nurtured it
over the years as well.
I am grateful to those initial students
who allowed us to work
so closely with them,
and to Kayla Suntory,
particularly to Dr. Black as
well, who passed last summer
but who was such a guiding light
as a wonderful mentor for
the students over the years.
I know she, wherever she
is, is pleased to see
that this program is thriving
to see the work that her students
she worked with are doing,
and to see that all of
you have continued to do
and participate in a
program that is thriving.
So again, thank you.
Congratulations to all STARS,
to the administrative have followed,
and it's the wonderful
work that we see coming out
of the program itself.
Congratulations.
- Thank you very much
Secretary Goff-Crews,
and thank you for founding STARS.
Our next speaker is Kurt Zilm,
the William K. Lanman Jr.
Professor of Chemistry and Chair
of the Department of Chemistry at Yale.
Professor Zilm.
- Thank you Sandy.
It's a real pleasure to be here.
I, you know, it's hard
to believe 25 years,
I would have never
thought starting with AMPS
and I've got to mention
one name I haven't heard
is Bob Weimann, Professor of NCDB,
who I think really was the founder.
I've been given credit
for a lot of things,
about why AMPS started,
especially when this
became an HHMI Program
and then we've ever since,
you know, through many rounds of funding,
you know, when this was innovative,
across the country we were copied,
it was the most sincere form of flattery
by other universities copying
what was done in STARS.
But after about 15 years
or so, 10 or 15 years,
funding agencies started saying,
"Well, this isn't innovative anymore.
This is just something you should do.
We don't need to provide
seed funding anymore."
And so it's been my...
My goal has been to push the institution
to find a way to endow this
program into fully funded.
It's so fulfilling to hear first from,
at the time was Dean
Holloway and now Dean Chang,
and to hear in the Yale science priorities
that this is an institutional priority
and it's not a question of if but when,
and I hope you're all able
to participate and help us,
you know, in this goal of making
certain this program is fun
and it can be expanded
for future generations of Yale students.
I wish you were all here.
There's so much has changed
since you were on campus
many of you.
There has been an enormous
amount of building
that's going on.
I'm speaking to you
with the background
for my renovated office
in Sterling Chemistry
and I'm very proud of my labs
that are in Sterling Chemistry,
but the spaces that you were
probably most familiar with,
you know, where maybe you
took a class in SCL 160
which is about half
again, bigger than it was
with the demonstration hoods,
the old teaching labs that
you had with the wooden sashes
have been replaced by an
amazing new teaching facility
where every student in organic chemistry
gets their own hood to use.
It's just an amazing really facility
that just showcases
Yale's commitment to STEM.
There's a new research building.
That's actually Sterling.
There's a new research
building for chemistry
and there is now a new biology building
that's replaced Gibbs,
which is amazing.
So it, you know, I really
wish we were on campus.
I hope we have an on-campus one
so you'd all get a chance
to see the facilities
that STARS students are
able to work in now.
And I'm very excited to hear about,
in the breakout sessions where...
What you've all been up to and to catch up
and hopefully be able to engage you
to help feature first
STARS students and Yale
as we try to fully fund this program.
Thank you,
and welcome.
- Thank you very much Professor Zilm.
Our first STARS alumni
speaker is Carissa Sanchez.
The facility administrator
at DaVita Dialysis Clinic.
Carissa.
- Hi, can everyone hear me all right?
All right. Sounds good.
Thank you so much for having
me with you guys this morning.
I'm very excited to be here.
I was a mechanical engineering major
and graduated from Yale in 2015,
and then went on to really to
do actual engineering work.
So I worked with Alcoa.
We were doing a lot of
aerospace manufacturing
for jet engine components,
and got a lot of my exposure there.
I came in through the
STARS Summer Program,
and maybe like a lot of other, you know,
first-generation URM students,
I honestly had no idea
what I wanted to study
and yeah, very much joined STARS
and very luckily matched
with the Schroeder's material science
and mechanical engineering lab,
and was really grateful
for the mentorship,
especially of Kyla who I see them today,
and yeah, I was able to find out
that I really enjoyed the research.
I also kind of serendipitously found
that there was a very strong connection
with these materials
that we were developing
that could be used for
healthcare applications.
And I ended up staying
with that same lab I found
during my start summer for
all four years of undergrad,
and was able to help a PhD student
develop these diabetes
blood glucose sensors
out of the materials we were developing,
and that kind of spurred the
rest of my career honestly
because I had this light bulb moment
where I realized that, you know,
I'm from a ton lots of nation
and my tribe has the
highest rate of diabetes
for any people group
from across the world.
So over 50% of the TRIPOD diabetes,
five or 10 or 25 years old,
and just STARS, you know, curriculum
and being able to go through that
just really lit a fire underneath
to be able to have a
good career within STEM
but also to do something
good for my people
in underrepresented community.
So, you know, going through
my actual engineering job,
it was fun, I was learning a lot.
I also wanted to do more
and, you know, get back to doing something
that would impact my people.
So I went to business school,
I'm a little off the
be impact for typical,
you know, STEM engineering student,
and wound up, you know,
kind of serendipitously finding DaVita
who provides a lot of dialysis care,
and they're also on the innovation front
of how do we address things like diabetes
and just general chronic kidney disease
from a big healthcare scale
and not just what a
doctor or a nurse is doing
every single day with the patients.
So I joined the DaVita
Program after my MBA,
after spending a summer with CCG
and kind of getting additional
health care contacts there.
And yeah, it's been a whirlwind.
I graduated from business
school in a little bit
about a year ago, so May 2020.
And it's been a fascinating
time to be in a dialysis clinic
during COVID when we were short staffed
or when things were going crazy,
I was the person who was, you know,
running out to the parking lot
and giving patients COVID tests.
So got a lot of good exposure there.
And it's been really heartwarming
to see that, you know,
the path from, you know,
a rural public school
to Yale through STARS,
you know, through a
business school program
has led me to be able
to have a strong impact
where, you know, I have a Navajo patient
who can't figure out how
to apply for Medicare,
I can help with that.
And it's very rewarding
to be able to do that.
So I want to encourage,
you know, the whole class
here and more recent alumni
that your path may be winding.
I know we come into Yale thinking
like I'm gonna be a doctor
I'm gonna be a psychologist,
I'm gonna be an engineer,
you know, the world throws
different things your way.
So be okay with that. It's
not the end of the world
if plan A doesn't go exactly
how it was supposed to.
Certainly for me I had no idea
that I would wind up in kidney care,
working directly with
native American populations,
which is, you know, very much the dream,
but it wasn't expected.
I would also like to encourage you guys
to just take up space.
I think during my time at Yale,
I very much just like put my head down,
I think kind of on
stereotypical front minorities
are trained to be quiet,
just like get through it and do well,
but not raise the rockets.
I think so much of my success was linked
to having close relationships
with the professors
and the PhD students and different mentors
who were really invested in our success,
and of course said like "You're
welcome to pop by anytime,"
but what that means is you
will be so much better off
and have a much easier go of this
if you take up that office hour space
if you go have one-on-one
and build this relationship.
So, you know, all of us here
speaking on the panel today
are very invested in
current student success,
so please reach out to any of us.
I'm very open to that,
very excited to pave the way
for you guys to do even
even better than we've done.
So, thanks for having me here today.
- Thank you very much Carissa
for those essential advice.
Our next speaker is Courtney Williams,
Senior Staff Scientist,
Oncology and Angiogenesis Department
at Regeneron Pharmaceuticals.
Courtney.
- Thanks so much Dean Chang.
I'm hoping you all can see my slides.
My name's Courtney Williams.
I am class of O1.
This is my 20th reunion year,
and I am glad Carissa went right before me
because I think it is
important to remember
that your path can be a winding one
even though mine was not.
So I did go kind of straight shot
from undergrad to grad
school to a postdoc to a job.
And some of that was kind of financial
not wanting to have my
loans come out of deferment
and things like that,
but I think as the first
two speakers were examples
that the paths can differ
and you can still get
to where you wanna go.
So that's some old pictures
here for everybody.
So, I was at Yale from...
I'm sorry, I'm just gonna have a point
or second point people out.
From 1997 to 2001,
I majored in MBMB and I
was able to participate
in STARS I, STARS Summer, STARS II,
all of that thanks to Dr. Iona black,
who you heard mentioned
earlier, who's right here,
who saw me in her chemistry class
and just for whatever reason decided to...
Like I was gonna be in her program
and she was gonna make
sure that that happened.
And it allowed me to get into a lab.
I worked with Dr. Joann Sweasy
who was part of the larger
graduate school faculty
but her lab was in the Department
of Therapeutic Radiology
at the Yale School of Medicine.
She since moved her lab
recently to Arizona.
But there I worked on
Polymerase-Beta interacting proteins
during DNA mismatch repair
in mammalian miosis.
And just to give you an idea
these are some of my friends from STARS.
Now a doctor, now a physician's assistant,
now doing research,
Jessica is in your program.
That's, she and I were
there at the same time.
Some of you might remember Dean George.
So lots of folks went
on to successful careers
in science and law and
lots of other things.
But when I finished up at Yale,
I considered staying there for grad school
but felt like I kind of
needed to leave the nest.
And so I went to Princeton
where I was in the Department
of Molecular Biology
and it was a relatively
small program at the time.
It's since grown tremendously
since I've been there.
I was in the lab of
Dr. Jean Schwartzbauer,
and I've just put some
of my publications here
just so students can get
an idea of the kind of work
that I did in these various labs.
But my project was
looking at breast cancer
and the role of the extracellular
matrix protein fibronectin
in breast cancer
initiation and progression.
And I did use the 3D culture system
that was pretty cumbersome
and not the best way
to look at these problems and
ask these kinds of questions
about the role of matrix and stiffness
in breast cancer progression.
And at a conference that I went to,
senior scientists suggested
to think of your career
like a tool box.
And what are the questions you wanna ask
and what tools do you
need in that toolbox,
and then pick your next steps
based on how to get those tools.
And so I took that advice to heart,
I realized that I knew
a lot about the biology
but I didn't know a lot
about the engineering
that it would take to design systems
that I really needed
to ask the kind of questions
that I wanted to ask.
So from there,
I went to MIT for my post-doc
in the lab of Dr. Linda Griffith
in the Department of
Biological Engineering.
And some people do know her,
she's a MacArthur genius grant winner
but if you've ever seen the
picture of the nude mouse
with a human ear growing on its back,
that was her post-doctoral
research that produced that.
And so in her lab there at MIT
I basically was able to
up my engineering game
and work on designing culture systems
to help maintain the function
of primary hepatocytes.
Which is important for drug testing
because if these cells don't
maintain their differentiation
then you can't look at
toxicity because you don't know
if drugs are being properly metabolized.
But so I worked with a
team of material scientists
and other engineers to come
up with two different systems
for culturing these primary hepatocytes
to get them to maintain that function.
And when I went looking for a job,
I had previously seen information
about Regeneron Pharmaceuticals
and it was near where I grew up.
I grew up in the Hudson
Valley in New York State
and it turns out my cousin's
wife's best friend from high
school worked at Regeneron.
And I found that out through LinkedIn
and that connection I
had, I talked with her,
my cousin put me in touch
and she sent my CV on to the
HR department at Regeneron,
and it turned out that they
were looking for someone
to design in vitro cell culture systems
to compliment their in vivo tumor work.
And basically I was kind of
the perfect candidate for that
because I came from a background of,
instead of year one,
culture system is the solution
for all engineering needs.
I approached it from a much more like
"What signals do you need?
This is how we can ask those questions."
And so I've been there for 10 years,
and I started as a scientist
and I've studied a bunch
of different things
as well as doing a lot of STEM outreach,
these are some of my publications here,
and I can talk more about
that in the breakout group
'cause I don't wanna go over time,
and I definitely want time for this slide.
So this is the T-shirt that
I still have with our logo
from the STARS Summer in 1999.
That is me,
and that is my friend
Lauren, who's now a doctor,
and some more pictures
we've got, you know,
a Marine biologist,
we've got some lawyers,
there's Dr. Black,
researcher, wealth capital.
I looked up some folks last night,
wealth capital person,
doctor at Memorial Sloan Kettering.
So a lot of people went on to
do a lot of successful stuff.
We've got people in education,
plenty of doctors.
I still run into STARS people
working in the various areas
of the life sciences,
but it's definitely been,
STARS was instrumental into
helping me stay in science
and be successful in science.
And I really owe that all to Dr. Black,
who was leading STARS when
I was an undergraduate
and kind of saw something in me,
and decided to really despite
my resistance to joining STARS
really decided to make
sure I got in the program,
and she really was a champion
for me as an undergraduate
and the program that
STARS was with Dr. Nelson
was really instrumental into
my success as an undergrad
and leaving me very well
prepared for graduate school.
So with that, I am
finished a little over time
but I look forward to talking
to students in the breakout,
in the breakout groups.
So, thanks so much.
- Thank you very much Courtney.
Our next speaker is Thomas Howard,
a current medical student at
Harvard MIT MD/PhD program.
Thomas.
- Thank you Sandy.
I hope everyone can see my slides here.
I wanted to speak briefly today
about some of my experiences
as a first-generation college student,
and in particular how in medical
school it really felt like
all of my classmates had
physicians for parents.
And now this wasn't quite true, of course,
but there definitely seemed
to be this wealth of knowledge
that many of my classmates had,
that wasn't taught in our classrooms
and weren't in any of our books.
And I've one of the many examples of this
on my very first rotation
coming back from my PhD years
was surgery,
and the intern handed me
a copy of the patient list
that might've looked something like this,
and it's mostly a list of
tasks that need to get done,
and as the medical student,
you're trying to be helpful,
you're trying to get some of
these done for the residents.
And as you can see, so much of medicine
has all of this shorthand and acronyms
to try to figure out what's going on
with each of these patients,
and fortunately I knew many of this.
But there was one acronym
that was popping up
all over the place, NTD
and I had no idea what that meant.
I was racking my brain
to try to figure out
what test or antibiotic or
whatever this might mean
and when I failed at that,
I did whatever every
did medical student does
which is consult Dr. Google.
But every place that I looked,
the only thing I saw for
NTD was a Neural Tube Defect
which is something that can
happen in the developing fetus
and certainly was not
the medical abbreviation
that I was looking for.
So I sheepishly asked the intern,
I said I'm so sorry if I should know this,
but could you please
tell me what NTD means.
And then that's when she said
it just means nothing to do.
It wasn't a medical abbreviation at all,
it was just a shorthand
on that list of tasks.
Now, when I think back
at what has been 13 years
of higher education,
I really appreciate the
fact that I had a chance
as part of the STARS Summer program,
to learn many of these things.
And so that's both the
programming that recognizes
that not all of us come in
with the same background
and the same information,
but then more importantly
connecting us with mentors
who can try to help us
navigate those waters.
At that point, I had no idea
what graduate school was
or what one might do with a PhD
or what being a PI might be like.
And I'm so thankful for Steve and Maria
who welcomed me into their lab
and taught me all of these things,
and then put me on the road
to applying for MD/PhD
programs after Yale.
I was also very fortunate
to have great PhD mentors at Harvard,
and particularly people who
could model what it was like
to care for patients as
well as to run a lap.
And now I think many of you guys
are already experiencing that.
As soon as you want information
you can start passing
that on to others as well.
And so one of the things
that I'm most proud of
of my time in those
labs is that I recruited
and was able to mentor
an undergrad, Melinda
and a research technician, Taylor,
who were both phenomenal
and so helpful for our work.
And we had all of these people contribute
to many of them who were post-docs
or professors themselves,
and it was Melinda and Taylor
who we were able to
give the most credit for
as part of this team effort.
And what I'm most proud of
is we were also able to help
them even in just little ways
to get them into medical school themselves
and they're gonna move
on with their dreams
to become doctors as well.
And lastly, I just wanted to mention
that the greatest gift I got from Yale
was meeting my now wife, Tara.
We got annexed from our colleges,
junior year to Arnold hall.
I'm not sure if that's
something that still happens
but if that's an experience you're having,
there might be some unexpected
positives that come from it.
So thank you all for listening.
I'm so excited that we'll be able to talk
with some of you later on,
and I'm very happy to reach out by email
or anything that I can be
helpful with in the future.
- Thank you very much Thomas.
Our next speaker is Aida Behmard
who's a current graduate
student and NSF fellow.
Aida.
- Yeah, sure.
So right, my name is Aida Behmard.
I graduated from Yale in
2015 with a BS in Physics,
and I was a STARS II student
and I'm currently a grad student
in Planetary Science at Caltech.
So my current research
is focused on exoplanets
which is basically exactly
what they sound like.
They're planets that exist
outside the solar system,
orbiting stars other than the sun.
So these days I'm working on
projects to try and tease out
possible correlations between
the chemical compositions
of the stars that host these exoplanets
and the types of the planets themselves.
So one example of this could be,
does a star rich in rocky
elements like iron or magnesium
tend to host planetary systems
of a certain type like say,
maybe close in gas giants
or rather smaller multi planet systems.
And figuring out these
sorts of correlations
can tell us more about the
chemical histories of planets
outside our solar system
which I find super fascinating
because I think of other
planets as not just things
but other places,
places that we can learn more about
and maybe travel to one day,
and maybe amenable to hosting life.
So I'm super grateful for the start
I got in science research at Yale,
a large part of which was
participation in the STARS program
which allowed me to conduct research
in the Astro departments,
and also gave me access to
a community of scientists
who were working on really cool research
that was very different from my own
which is always nice to hear about.
And the mentorship I
received as a STARS student
was also super helpful for me.
I was able to build close
relationships with postdocs
and other senior scientists at Yale,
who also were women of color
and who were honest with me
about challenges that I
might face in grad school,
and encouraged me that I
would be able to do it anyway.
So these days when I'm
not working on science
I spend a lot of time on diversity, equity
and inclusion initiatives at Caltech.
I currently serve as the diversity chair
on the grad student council
and we do everything
that we can to support
and advocate for Caltech grads
with marginalized identities.
I'm also really passionate
about science education outreach
and I've been going into
Pasadena Elementary Schools
as part of a grad student team
to teach bi-weekly science classes
for the better part of
the last four years.
I honestly didn't think I
would spend so much time
on outreach and DI initiatives
when I got to Caltech,
but it turns out that Caltech,
while an exceptional institute
for science and research
is not the most diverse place,
which I think on some level
can be said about any scientific community
especially once you climb
past the undergrad level.
So when I came and saw how it was
I really wanted to do everything to help
that was in my power.
So if you're interested in
talking to me about any of that
or my science or anything at all
I'd be super happy to do so later.
- Thank you very much Aida.
Our next speaker is Ben Bartolome
who is a current Data Scientist
at Navy Federal Credit Union.
Ben.
- Hey, good morning everyone.
Yeah, my name is Ben Bartolome,
class of 2016.
Majored in Chemical Engineering,
and I'm now a data scientist
at a pretty big credit union.
Before I start, I want to give
a shout out to my girl, Mary
who's a current STARS I student,
super awesome, really
incredible person and all the...
And I really look forward to chatting
with as many of you as
possible in the coming years.
In terms of how STARS has
impacted me in my journey,
I want to give a few
pretty material examples
but on perhaps like on
the softer skill side.
The ability to clearly communicate
as perhaps better evidence than
Courtney and Thomas's slides
is really, really important.
And you'll see some abysmal
truly important things
as you go about your life.
And so I'm gonna give you an example.
I just had this slide shown
to me earlier this week
and at work about,
they're about 200 slides,
this one stood up the most.
And these were created
by Accenture consultants
who get paid six figures.
And you don't have to know
what any of this means.
I don't know what any of this means,
but someone sat down,
they built this slide and they thought,
"Yeah, this is really the clearest way
to communicate this information.
This is abysmal.
Who knows what's going on here?"
And then ironically that
half year in the middle
some circle thing that
says elicit and clarify.
This is a joke.
And so, you know,
this would not be a professional
ano approved, I'm sure,
but in terms of clear communication
this is the way to not do it.
STARS will help you
get on the right track.
To start everybody off,
well, in terms of other things,
and thankfully there's a
breakout room on this later
which is awesome,
but STARS also taught me how
to be a really good mentee
and also an improving mentor,
which is to say that like as
a mentee and also as a mentor,
but like,
you know,
throughout your journey with STARS
you get the opportunity to
learn how to listen well,
to give conversations
like the space to breathe,
how to enter conversations
with like a humility
and an open mind,
asking thoughtful questions of the people
that you're in dialogue with.
And then, you know, on either
side of the interaction,
the ability to like
for consistent followup
and you know, there's a type
of thing where, you know,
your mentor or advisor
or whoever that you
might be reaching out to,
you know, reaching out,
it doesn't have to be like
a kind of continuous thing,
it can be,
but even something as perhaps 'infrequent'
as a six months to a
year that type of thing,
but it's super valuable.
And it also emphasizes, you know,
in terms of this like
mentor/mentee relationship
that there's like so many people,
so many alums that want that help.
You know, I think right now in total
in terms of the veal alums,
there's like 175,000 plus.
The overwhelming majority of them
do not get reached out to
and they would love to help.
And be like this is the way
in which you can differentiate yourself,
there's a massive massive amount of wisdom
that's available out there, right?
And if you just reach out,
there's a really high
likelihood that they'll say,
"Oh yeah, (indistinct)"
and you can have access to that.
A really great example of
that on my end is that,
excuse me,
I am looking to start a
company soon with some friends
and I needed some insight,
kind of on the legal side
and in the financial sector.
And so I reached out to this one alumni
who was the formerly a commissioner
of the security and exchange
commission under Obama,
and I was like, "Hey, can I
get your insight on this?"
And she gave all kinds of
really valuable insight,
and it was just by my reaching out
and she was happy to help,
and now she kind of
continues to be an advisor
to me in many ways.
But you know, all I had to do was ask.
And so yeah, this concept
of being, you know,
a good mentee and similarly
on the mentor side
where you can develop your soccer skills
under ordinarily (indistinct).
And so yeah.
And then the last thing
I wanna shout about
and this is on a more personal
level, similar to Thomas,
is that I want to talk about my...
What else? Something
else that STARS provided
was an avenue to meet my current wife.
I met my wife, Brooke, over STARS Summer.
You can actually see that,
even by graduating pretty
recently, we were...
This camera quality was
actually the best technology
that was available.
It was a few years ago, but
it's kind of incredible.
You know, science really
does progress very quickly
and starts (indistinct).
So thank you.
We were on the bus to the beach.
Here you can see that we are on a boat.
You can tell by our posturing
that we were extremely popular,
even though we're standing by ourselves,
and you may be thinking,
"Man, how did this guy
come to sit before you
and he's presenting in this panel?"
Well, a few years later,
you can have a glow up just
like this boom, we made a baby.
And so Brooke and I got
married a few months ago,
August 2020.
I dunno, we were the, as Mary put it,
the first STARS crossed
lovers to get married.
Hopefully we're not the last,
but you know, have fun with it.
It's good time.
STARS will, you know, in many ways
help set you up on the path and
a very fruitful (indistinct)
Thanks guys for listening.
- Thank you so much Ben.
That was terrific.
Our next speaker is Clarence Agbi,
a Senior Data Scientist at Brex.
Clarence.
- Hello, thanks for the introduction.
My name is Clarence Agbi, class of 2009,
which is a while ago at this point.
Majored in electrical engineering.
I was part of Calhoun
now Grace Hopper College.
And if you all remember
nothing from this conversation
or this talk,
I absolutely want you to
remember this one thing
that, you know, basically
Carissa stole it, already,
is make your own lane, make your own path,
and don't be afraid to pivot, right?
And so one of the things
that I'll, you know,
kind of talk about is my own path,
my own journey through STEM
and how STARS played a role in that.
For me I'm originally from New York,
so shout out to any New
Yorkers on the call,
son of immigrants,
you know, shout out to all of you as well.
Came to Yale
and I wasn't really sure
what my path was gonna be.
I mean, I was into like AP
math, AP science and all of that
but, you know, I came to Yale
just to give myself the option of like
"What if I wanted to be an English major
or an econ or a Spanish major,"
'cause these were all
things I was interested in.
And I would say definitely econ 115,
is that the introductory course?
It definitely crushed
all of my hopes of that.
I think I got a C in that class.
Quickly learned English was not for me,
Spanish also not great for me,
even though that summer
after freshman year
I worked at a temp agency as
part of Bulldogs in the Rockies
translating basically
from English to Spanish
job requirements and things like that.
So, you must be wondering like, well,
what does this have to
do with engineering?
All of this is kind of like
on the journey of things
that failed for me, right?
And ultimately I figured out
sometime around sophomore year
that I was really really into engineering.
And I think freshman year I took physics
but it wasn't until I took
some of the hardcore engineering
classes that I was like
oh yeah, this is really clicking for me.
This is really making sense.
And you know, in that time,
during sophomore year,
I think one class that
really stood out for me
was Professor Cruz's class EE 350.
I don't even know if they
still have that class
but professor Cruz
essentially ran the digital,
I think it's the acoustics lab.
He was really into like bots and acoustics
but essentially it was all about robotics,
and how do you use systems to
do very intelligent things.
And in that class,
he had us build like a
differential drive robot,
which I had never done before,
I thought, wow, this is really cool.
And that really picked my interest
and got me thinking about grad school.
The summer after sophomore year,
I ended up going to a
program similar to STARS,
it was NSF funded, but
it was at Georgia Tech,
with predominantly minority
black and brown people, women,
and it really made room
for me to one, do research
at an institution and two,
just figure out how to
get into grad school
'cause it was such an ambiguous process,
and it just felt like a
big barrier and a big hump.
So did that, and I would say
that program specifically,
much like STARS I at Yale,
really made me wanna be a PhD student.
I mean, I came back from
my summer in Atlanta
and I was like research,
where can I do more of it?
And that's where at that point,
Dean George kind of
intersect and was like,
"Have you heard of STARS II?"
And by the way, I should say
a lot of the STARS I folks
are very tight knit.
I kind of have a little bit of FOMO
about not doing that program,
but you know, I didn't
wanna be in New Haven
not one moment longer during the summer.
So (laughs),
so I left.
But when I came back,
like I said, junior
year I put my head down
and I talked to Professor Coots
and I was like let's do
some research together.
And so I applied to STARS
II, was a STARS II student
and did research for
about a year and a half,
which eventually turned
into my senior project.
In that year and a half,
I learned a lot about ambiguity.
I learned a lot about scoping projects.
I trekked.
I lived at Becton lab and I
trekked often to the FM house
where I did, you know, I
was normal person, right?
So I didn't just do research 24/7.
I was part of like,
you know, gospel choir,
I was part of stepping out, you know,
I saw people,
I had to maintain a social
life and be a real person.
But on top of that,
I was also really motivated to do research
and to get into grad school
and do all of these wonderful things.
And I was really gun hold
about sticking on this path
of research, right?
So, you know, eventually
things worked out.
I ended up,
like I said, it became my senior project.
You can actually Google it.
I think the YouTube link is out there,
you can ask me about it later.
And I got into, you know,
something that people won't
often tell you is that
some of these programs are a
little bit of a crap shoot.
So I got into two of the
eight graduate programs
that I applied to,
and I was lucky enough to
get into Carnegie Mellon
for my MS/PhD program.
So, you know, don't feel bad
if you don't get into all of
the things that you wanna do.
My motto is to kind of fail
forward and fail often, right?
And like I said early, you
know, don't be afraid to pivot.
So I went to CMU, did
hardcore engineering there,
actually did research in smart
buildings as part of like,
I was also an NSF
graduate research fellow.
So I was doing research and how
do we make buildings smarter
and build really fancy
control systems to do that,
I was writing proofs for days,
and ultimately after
five years of doing that,
you know, I was freaked out.
I couldn't go any further.
So, you know, hats off
to you, Dr. Williams,
and to all the other
doctors that stayed on,
you know, and did research
and became professors.
I took a completely different route
and was like I'm going into industry.
I became a software engineer
at a defense company
and then eventually pivoted
into this very brand new thing
called data science.
And at the time it was brand new,
now everybody is kind of like,
"Oh yeah! Data science, that's the thing."
But I say all of this to say that,
in, you know, the process of
me getting to where I am now,
where I feel like I'm in a job
that completely suits all of my abilities,
some of these things
didn't exist at that time.
And I think it's okay
that it doesn't exist now,
you know, you might be
built to do something
that is completely brand new.
You might not be built
for the traditional path
or you might not be built
for the non-traditional path either.
There's a lot of ambiguity and
stress and imposter syndrome
and all of that there as well.
So, you know, definitely feel free to go
to all the breakout rooms,
but definitely come to mind,
if you wanna talk a little bit more,
I can speak to just about
anything in that experience
right from, you know, Yale to grad school,
to what it's like now working
in the engineering world,
in tech and where to go from there.
Certainly my career is still taking pivots
and I'm still making a path for myself,
so I don't claim to
have it all figured out
and I don't think any
of the other speakers do
but certainly we can help
you where you are now
and you know, work
together on the journey.
So, thanks for that.
- Thank you very much Clarence.
Our next speaker is Raul Navarro,
Assistant Professor of
Chemistry at Occidental College.
Raul.
- Hey everybody.
My name is Raul Navarro.
I am currently an assistant professor
at Occidental College
in Southern California.
First off, I just wanted to say
I'm really excited to see
so many familiar faces.
Clarence, Tina, some of my classmates,
Dean Chun, who I knew as Master Chun
of Berkeley College back then,
Professor Zilm who I
didn't have the pleasure
of taking a class with
but I remember your face very well
spending a lot of time in Sterling.
So, let's see,
I guess I'll tell you
a little bit about how
I got involved with STARS
and how it led to where I am today.
You know, it's sort of it is that
it essentially molded my,
the person I am today in a lot of ways.
I started Yale coming from,
I was born and raised in LA,
you know, son of immigrant parents
who had just come from Mexico, right?
And, you know, they kind
of just came over here
to give us all these opportunities.
And so I took that very seriously as a kid
and I was lucky enough to get into Yale
thinking I was going to do pre-med.
Everyone's kind of touched on this idea
of these meandering paths, right?
And so that was mine.
I was definitely pre-med
when I first started.
I had a general vague sense of, you know,
I wanted to help people,
but I don't think I really
understood how then at the time.
And then I tried the STARS program.
I remember the end of my
freshman year there was this,
you know, I saw a flyer for it.
I was like, well, med schools
look for research experience,
let's give it a shot.
And honestly the rest is history.
I had my first summer research experience.
Dr. Black was the person who
really helped me out there.
You know, I'm really embedded to her
because I still remember the fact
that it was like a few weeks
before the summer started
and I still hadn't picked out a lab
which apparently I was supposed to do.
And so Dr. Black of course
comes in is, you know,
essentially hold my hand
through the entire process,
which I really needed at the time
'cause I had no clue what I was doing,
and helped me figure out
a lab, a chemistry lab.
I still remember the
first day of my time there
because it was such a
crazy experience for me.
I'd never seen anything like it.
Grad school to me was
such a foreign thing.
And I was there in that
first day thinking like wow,
I was in a lab and just an amazement
that I could do something
like that and get paid for it.
That to me was just such a crazy concept.
And so, you know, the rest is history.
I enjoyed my time there.
It was tough.
You know, learning a lot of the
stuff you do as a researcher
when you had just taken general chemistry.
But I got a lot of great
training in that first summer.
I then took organic chemistry,
my second year of class
that I think a lot of people dread taking.
And I certainly wasn't a
big fan my first semester
but once I think I devoted more time to it
and went to office hours
and got a lot of help for it
I became really good at it
and really wanted to do research in it.
And so then I approached
my professor at the time,
let me do research,
he's no longer at Yale,
but he graciously let me be in his lab.
And that's when I really
I think found that the
great intersection of,
for me, the kind of
research that I wanted to do
where it kind of overlapped
with a lot of my interests.
So for me, it was kind of
about building molecules
and that I thought was really cool.
So I did that for the
rest of my time at Yale.
It was more or less two years
that I was in Professor
Glenn Micalizio's lab,
and the decision to apply
to grad school for me
wasn't necessarily a conscious one.
I reached a point in my junior year
where I was thinking about grad schools
without having sort of
thought about the fact
that I was no longer
like a pre-med student
and was actively thinking about like,
I'm gonna be in graduate school next.
And so for me it was kind of a decision
that was kind of made for me in that way.
And so, let's see, I...
So after Yale, you know, I
also applied to grad school.
Clarence mentioned, you know,
really grad school really
is kind of a crapshoot.
You'll get into places and
you're gonna think like,
I got in here but I didn't get it here.
It's like it doesn't make any sense.
But that's just how it goes, right?
So I was excited to get into Caltech.
And so I went back to...
And I will also kind of
missing, being in California,
having spent...
I love Yale but I didn't love the weather.
This is the summary of
my four years at Yale.
So I came back to do my PhD at
Caltech where I did chemistry
and you know, my experience there,
I'm happy to talk about it
in the breakout sessions,
I had a great time there.
I, you know, I got a chance to really dive
into more organic chemistry research
thinking about making these,
you know, what we refer to as
these, you know, natural products,
molecules you can isolate from nature
that have some interesting
biological properties,
potentially treat some human disease.
Where I really got a
chance to explore that
and also really develop
my senses of identity
that has accumulated all
up at Yale, to be honest.
And so, you know, I think Aida mentioned,
you know, starting to do
things outside of the research
(indistinct) and I think for
me that was also equally true.
I got a chance to really
start to develop a sense of,
I guess, balance between
research and celebrating who I am
and pursuing those interests.
And so I became really
involved with reviving
and really establishing the
LGBT group on campus at Caltech,
which was really a rewarding experience.
And so, you know, coming
out of grad school,
I'm running out of the time here,
I did a post-doc.
And so I went up to Stanford University
to do some research in chemical biology,
trying something a little bit different,
applying some of the
compounds that I, you know,
developed or made in grad school
and thinking more broadly about how to,
how they can be used to study
some sort of biological function.
So I went up there and
spent three or four years,
almost four years as a post-doc.
Also happy to unpack that experience
Each of these transitions,
I think we all, you know,
you get thrown for a loop
in what you're doing
and in each one of these I
think was super challenging
for me in a lot of ways.
And really what it came down to for me
was just starting to develop
a sense of community, right?
I think Aida mentioned, I
forget who else mentioned,
as you go up, as you
climb beyond undergrad
your community starts to
get noticeably smaller,
almost exponentially smaller
as you climb each rank.
And so it becomes a lot more important
to make sure you establish
those connections
to make sure you recognize that
you're not doing this alone,
that you're not kind of swimming
in your head by yourself
which I often find myself doing.
Navigating imposter syndrome,
is one of those things
that it's very challenging
and it never really leaves you.
And so it's good to
develop good techniques
including reaching out to people.
And so now I get a chance to,
do a little bit of research
at a liberal arts institution.
And so we're really focused on teaching.
I get to do a lot of teaching
and really think about
really creative ways
to deliver classes like organic chemistry.
I have a group of
undergraduate researchers.
And so that's been really rewarding.
Something I got to do at
Yale was STARS I, STARS II.
I did all of the STARS things basically
since the end of my freshman year,
I got a chance to be a
facilitator and tutor people
and that's something that
I think really inspired me
to keep doing that sort
of kind of work today.
And then I guess one last
thing in terms of advice
I think to give to the younger students is
I would say to make sure
you let yourself take opportunities.
So it's one thing to take an opportunity
and people tell you that,
but it's a whole nother to be
in a mindset where you can say
"I can do that."
And I think I struggled a lot
with that as an undergrad,
always kind of second guessing myself
and not being sure
that's not really for me.
Kind of shutting it down
before I even consider it.
And so that's sort of one
I think mental barrier
that I took a lot of time to overcome.
And so this, I think,
you have a lot of opportunities
while you're at Yale,
and I think it's just
important to make sure
that you put yourself in a
position where you can say yes,
I can try that,
and yes, I can do it as well.
I'm happy to...
I'm looking forward to
chatting with all of you
in the breakout sessions.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much Raul.
Our next speaker is Akpanoluo Etteh,
a Data Scientist and CEO.
- Excellent. Thank you so much Sandy.
By the way, I've been
messaging Dean George
and she says to say hi.
She also says to give a hug to Clarence.
(laughs)
Yes, once again my name is Akpanoluo.
I am a data scientist who
works as analytics lead
at Music Tech Startup band camp,
which helps support artists, musicians,
in actually making money
for their music online
in comparison to Spotify,
but we'll not get into that.
And I'm also the CEO and Chief
Curator of a music community
that I founded four years
ago called Sound Shop,
which is effectively a
ted talk meets a concert.
Musicians talk about their music
and they perform their music
and then have an intellectual conversation
with the audience.
So in terms of what I want
to talk to you guys about,
I would say that the important thing
that I want to impart on
you is two things actually.
The first is
that you should pursue
your intellectual curiosity
wherever that leads,
even if it leads you away
from what you perceived
to be your path.
And the other thing would be that,
even if you do go far a field
from what you expected your path to be,
that the time that you spent prior
is not wasted and that actually, you know,
you bring all of it with you
and you're actually able
to re reorient those skills
in powerful ways in new environments.
So I just want to kind of
kick this off metaphorically
with this painting that I painted.
I painted this in high school,
my senior year of high school.
So my mom's a painter,
and she's also an art
professor and art historian.
And she also encouraged
me to go into the sciences
like at the exclusion of the arts.
So there's this kind of like
constant dichotomy in me
around the arts versus the sciences.
And in conjunction with that,
you know, when I started at Yale
I was deciding between...
I knew that I wanted to do neuroscience
but I was trying to decide
between whether I wanted
to be on the more bio side of things
or the psych side of things.
And so being able to,
you know, spend a summer
in a neurobiology lab up at KBT
was very influential in sort
of helping me realize that,
you know, I want to go more
on the psych side of things
rather than the biology side of things.
But, you know, as I
continued down that path
I was thinking of becoming a doctor
and in the end,
you know, I decided that
that was not what I wanted.
And I realized ultimately
it was what my mom wanted me to do
and there's really no compromising
between what you want to do
and what your parents want you to do.
And I tried to convince myself otherwise,
but, you know, right before I graduated,
I called my mom and was like,
"Hey, I don't wanna become a doctor."
She's like, "What are you gonna do?"
I'm like, "I'm gonna go into advertising."
And my mom was like, "What?"
(laughs)
But, you know, I decided
to go that direction
because I basically saw that.
I figured that, you know, my
background in neuroscience
and psychology would be
useful for advertising.
To the degree that's true
in an entry level position in advertising,
not really necessarily the case,
but you know, my interest in STEM
and especially the
technology side of things
always saw me doing things
that were more technical
in any role that I was in.
And also the presentation
skills that I gained
through STARS and cultivated
through my research background
also proved hugely
instrumental in my journey.
And so, you know, as time
moved along, I moved,
and as I moved up in
the advertising world,
I became more and more technical.
So becoming a data analyst,
becoming then a data engineer
and ultimately a data scientist,
and all of that, I owe to,
you know, the STEM background
that I have.
And then along the way,
you know, mentorship has
always been important to me,
both within STEM,
sorry, both within STARS,
and then, throughout my
time as an undergrad.
And so as I sort of moved up in the world,
I have been,
you know, I've been mentoring people.
I've taken people who work
in the advertising business
and they're more client facing
and they're less technical,
and I kind of mentor them
into becoming technical.
So I've been able to have, you know,
a huge impact on the people around me.
And so, you know, I kind of
had this narrative in myself
as I was moving up the ranks that like,
oh, like all the stuff that I did before
was not really useful,
and why did I spend all that
time doing pre-med stuff.
But I think me being invited back to this,
has actually made me reflect on how
it's actually persisted with
me, which is really cool.
And then, I know I'm over time,
I actually timed myself
so that I wouldn't,
but the final thing is, you
know, my music community,
you know, you think like,
oh, you're doing this
music curation thing.
Like how does that relate
to your past background?
And for the longest time,
it didn't really relate
or at least I didn't see it as relating,
but I met this guy named Kyle Mengelkamp
who is a stroke survivor.
He had a massive stroke at age 11,
complete retrograde amnesia,
had to rehabilitate himself from scratch,
and now he's 20 years on from that stroke,
and he runs a brain community
where he brings together academics
and survivors of traumatic brain injuries
and they're all talking about the brain.
They're all like, you know,
mutually supporting each other.
And so he and I now do a
lot of collaborative events
around music in the brain.
And it's kind of like, you know,
it's kind of like the book
Musicophilia as like an event.
So we'll bring together
clinical psychologists
who run an institution around music
at Berkeley School of Music,
or we'll bring in like a psych academic
who's doing research on music.
Or, you know, practitioners
at the intersection of music
and the brain.
And in one of those events,
I actually gave a talk,
where I basically articulated my theory
that music is the baseline skill
upon which language is built.
And I supported that using evidence
from linguistics neuroscience,
what was it? Evolutionary
biology, clinical psychology,
and so I'm now in a
place where I'm like able
to bring the STEM background
into what once seemed
like a more sort of like, you know,
fully arts oriented sort of thing.
So back to bringing it all full circle,
you can have it all,
you can make the arts and
the sciences live together.
And so that's what I just
wanna convey to everyone.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much Akpanoluo.
Our next speaker is Tina Liu,
a research specialist at UC Berkeley.
Tina.
- All right, so first of
all, thanks for inviting me.
It's great to see all these alums doing
all these amazing things at this point
at all different sort of
stages of their career.
So thanks a lot for
this opportunity to come
and join this event today.
So I'm gonna be talking a little bit
about kind of my journey at Yale actually,
and also a bit after,
mainly focusing on one
particular recent kind of work
that I'm doing on RNA diagnostics,
related to COVID,
but I'll also give sort
of just short vignettes
of some of the past work
that I've also done before.
So as Sandy was saying,
I'm currently a Research
Specialist at Doudna Lab
where I actually just,
with a postdoc until very recently.
I was class of 2008 in
the STARS II program
in Lynne Regan's lab and MB&B.
And I think one sort of, you know,
this event really made me think about
what sort of is the common theme
that connects my past work.
'Cause I've worked on a couple,
several different areas,
and I really think that
one thing that drives
my sort of interest in research
is really understanding life
at the molecular level.
So, you know, obviously a
whole multicellular organism
is composed of cells,
and then if you zoom in more
it has these complex
intracellular structures
called organelles, and that
when you further break that down
into macromolecules,
which include proteins,
sugars, DNA, RNA, lipids,
that all kind of enable life to exist
which is just kind of an
amazing thoughts in me.
And so, I worked in a
couple of different areas.
One is engineering proteins
which are one type of macromolecule.
I'm looking at membrane proteins,
so the connection between
proteins and lipids.
So two different types of molecules,
and then more recently,
harnessing a type of proteins
called CRISPR-Cas nucleases
for RNA detection.
So again, looking at two
different interactions
between two different
types of macromolecules
and harnessing them
for different functions
outside of their endogenous function.
And so at Yale, what I was
doing at STARS II program
I was in Lynne Regan's
labs, she's since left Yale,
she's now at university of Edinburgh,
but she was a professor
in the MB&B department.
And she gave me this project
to try to design new proteins
based on this TPR protein,
which is a natural protein,
but we wanted to give it new properties
so that it could bind to a novel target
or any target that you want.
And then one of the examples
where the value of doing that
is that when you use
those design proteins here
to target any pathway in a cell.
So in this case,
the design protein that I was
actually a part of designing
and engineering, we could
put into yeast cells
and we could actually
inhibit the specific pathway
that was the protein bound was a part of.
And so that actually led
to my first, you know,
co-first author paper
from the STARS Program
was the work that I did in Lynne's lab
which is super exciting as an undergrad.
It's not something that I
expected that at the time
but it was amazing to just
have that continuous support
from STARS to start a research
project in my second semester
of freshman year and actually get it
to the point where we
could actually present it
and share it with the
scientific community.
So that was really, really
amazing experience starting off.
Then after Yale, I went to
Harvard for in the BBS program,
Biological and medical sciences,
where I really wanted to still work
on molecular interactions and events
but understand how they happened
in the context of cellular pathways.
And so I joined Tom Rapoport's lab,
that worked on how organelles
in the cell are shaped
and how the proteins,
so this particular family of protein
called Atlastin proteins,
how they interact with each other
and also with the membrane
to fuse membranes together.
And that it turns out to
be a key sort of event
in the formation of organelles,
which as many of you might've already know
are sort of the internal
compartments of rooms of a cell.
If you think of a cell as
a building and, you know,
the kitchen having a specialized function
and the bedroom, living room and so on.
So the organelles are kind of see,
had those compartmentalize
functions inside the cell.
And then after this, I went
to Jennifer Doudna's lab
at UC Berkeley,
and her lab works on CRISPR-Cas systems
which are actually
bacterial immune systems,
and these immune systems use
these protein RNA complex
called RNA-guided
nucleases that protect them
against invading viruses.
And one sort of key step, again,
if we look down to the molecular level
is that this immune pathway
requires the use of
these protein RNA factors
to really enact immunity essentially.
And so, as some of you
might've heard before us,
many of these types of nucleases
can be hardest for DNA
or RNA editing in cells.
So this is, you know, wide sort of ranging
of the applications that
are already kind of in use.
So there's genome editing,
there's imaging of DNA inside cells,
activating repressing certain genes
as well as RNA imaging and
editing and knock down.
And it's one of the kinds of values,
value of CRISPR-Cas,
is that it's not that it is the first time
that DNA editing has been achieved,
but it's a tool that's really
easy for people to use.
So it really democratizes, you know,
manipulation in biology.
But the thing that I ended up working on
actually this past year,
given that the pandemic
started last spring
or early last year,
a lot of labs on campus
really tried to think about
what we could do to help.
And one sort of area of
need was, of course testing.
And so we, a couple of
labs in our building
actually got together
and really just brainstorm lots of ideas
to figure out how can we use
CRISPR for RNA diagnostics.
This concept of using a CRISPR protein
to detect certain RNA sequences isn't new,
but the problem was that
previous approaches,
even though they worked,
they still need a higher sensitivity
and also higher speed for
them to be really relevant
and useful in clinical applications.
And so we came up with this idea
to try to more efficiently couple together
two different CRISPR proteins in tandem,
for really fast RNA sections.
So essentially it takes this system
that were kind of separate
systems before on their own,
but combine them together
to see if we could get a faster response.
And this is one example
of kind of the signal
that comes out.
So basically we're looking for something
that rises as you over time.
And so we had to make
a couple modifications
with this system,
actually get it working well.
So you can see on the left,
this is a perfect example
actually of, you know,
many people earlier, speaking of saying,
sometimes things don't work.
And you can see here on the left,
we tested multiple sort of concentrations
of the molecule that we wanted to detect
and we don't get very good signal,
but we found that actually
by really looking at the
function of this one protein,
that we could engineer its activator
by putting this kind of
pink modification here
to make it work better.
And essentially by just
introducing that single change,
you could see the
difference in signal here
from almost close to baseline
to this really robust response.
And that actually increased
our sensitivity by 100 fold.
And so it was just really
exciting to see this
as kind of, you know,
these moments in science
where a lot of times things
don't work the first time
and second time and third time,
but then when they do work that one time,
it's just a really incredible feeling.
And so we were able, ultimately,
to sort of in addition
incorporate other improvements
to get to a sensitivity that
was sort of clinically useful
which is attomolar concentration rate,
that's about 30 copies per
microliter of SARS-Cov-2
RNA in about 20 minutes.
And in addition, since we have
an on-campus for testing lab,
we're able to actually take
some samples that were leftover
from their lab,
and see if we could use our
assay to detect SARS-CoV-2 RNA
that were actually from patient samples.
And what you can see here,
so I won't go into too much detail
but this black line is essentially,
we're looking for a difference
between this black line
and the pink line.
And you can see here
that you can see this above the pink line
which means that it's positive.
And again for here,
this is actually with a lower viral load.
So this number means that there's
less viral particles there
there are RNA there,
and it's still above but
it's closer to baseline.
On the other hand, on negative samples,
all show that it was below
this pink baseline here.
So essentially we could
distinguish between positive
and negative samples at this range
of Ct values between eight and 29,
which corresponds to the
early infectious stages
of COVID-19.
And that's really nice for us
because essentially when you
want to control a pandemic
it's not necessarily you have to have
the absolute most sensitive
tests, in the world,
actually what's more
important in some cases
is be able to frequently test
and catch people at the
most infectious stages
when they're most likely to
spread it to other people.
And so it was really nice for
us to see that in this range,
between less than 29
where most positives in
this kind of group work,
we could actually able, we
were able to detect them
with this technology
that we had developed.
And so just to kind of conclude,
basically we found that these
unrelated CRISPR nucleases
that were from different sort of bacteria,
different biological systems,
could be really combined together
for fast and sensitive RNA detection.
And that makes it that simplicity also
of being this kind of a single reaction
makes it really amenable for rapid testing
which is often approved
as point of care diagnosis
compared to, for example,
traditional approaches,
which require, you know centralized labs,
a lot of equipment, trained personnel.
And I think just to end with,
I think again this sort
of goes toward the point
that if you have an understanding
of how the molecules work
to drive a process in life,
that can really lead to
innovations that are valuable
in biology research and medicine
that's not just true for this,
but also you can see
in my mentor Jennifer
Doudna's work on CRISPR,
that CRISPR is a natural bacterial system.
Nobody ever thought, you know,
it was not designed for genome editing,
but nowadays it's been widely adopted
for genome manipulation.
And so I think I have to end
by truly thanking the MB&B program
for really instilling that
appreciation for molecular events
and also STARS II for this support.
And of course mentors, Lynne Regan,
Jennifer Doudna, Tom Rapoport,
and also the great Doudna
Lab for their help.
I'm happy to talk more
at the breakout sessions.
- Thank you very much Tina.
Our last alumni speaker
today is Elias Quijano.
He's a current MD/PhD student
at Yale medical school
and my STARS I graduate coordinator.
Elias.
- Hi everyone.
Thanks for having me today.
My name is Elias.
I'm a, as Dean Chang mentioned,
currently an MD/PhD student at Yale,
but graduated from Yale
a long time ago in 2012.
You know, I've been really fortunate
to be part of the STARS program.
You know, I remember my first day at Yale
just feeling completely out of place.
So I'm from a small town in
Florida, Hialeah, Florida.
It's really small city in Miami.
And growing up just like in
a Spanish speaking community
with Spanish speaking parents,
I never felt out of place.
I always felt like I was home.
And when I got to Yale,
that feeling of belonging
was immediately swept away from me
and I immediately fell out of place then.
And I think many of
you here probably share
with some of that feeling.
And I remember, you know,
even the smallest things
it made me feel like a foreigner.
So one big thing in Florida
is wearing these silk shirts,
these (indistinct).
And I remember wearing one,
probably my first week at Yale.
And you know, one of my
floor mates made, you know,
some sort of a joke about my shirt.
And I just remember immediately feeling
like I didn't belong here.
And I think, you know, early grades,
you know, my first C at Yale
compounded that feeling
of not belonging at Yale,
feeling like I didn't belong
and really, you know, that
first year I felt really lost.
And I think serving currently
as the graduate student
coordinator for STARS I,
many students feel this way
and it really doesn't matter
what your background is
or where you're from,
it's really hard to feel
like you belong here,
especially if you're from a
underrepresented community
or a first generation college student,
it's really easy to feel lost
and feel like you don't have
a community here at Yale.
But I remember my sophomore year.
I interacted with with
Dean Garcia at la casa.
And she really pointed
me to the STARS program
and really pointed me to
people who made me feel like
like I did belong at Yale.
And she was one of the first people
who really introduced me to the program
and introduced me to the faculty members
that were part of STARS
that had sort of voluntarily chosen
to mentor students like myself
which was really remarkable
to me at the time.
And I think like many
of you have mentioned,
you know, Dr. Black was
just an absolute force.
I mean, you could sort of
be failing and messing up
and not be on time for something
and she was after you,
she was pushing you,
she was asking you why
you weren't showing up
to review sessions.
You know, I remember one time,
at the time when I was a student,
she was hosting these nightly
review sessions for chemistry,
and I think I missed it once.
And she was like, "Why aren't you here?
You're the student who
belongs here the most.
You need the most help."
And, you know, it was
that level of intensity
and that level of like, sort
of looking out for students
and chasing students down
that I think is really really remarkable
and really made Dr. Black
stand out among all of
the faculty members here.
You know she really chased after you.
And the same was true for Dr. Moreno.
So, you know, I ended
up doing STARS Summer,
and Dr. Moreno had a similar
energy and a similar force,
but you know, she really taught
me how to succeed in science
and how to succeed in STEM.
And that to me was a
really really remarkable
just having someone
who was so accomplished
in her own field, in her own right,
take the time to mentor me and shepherd me
and just teach me what I
needed to know from, you know,
how to write an email that was
appropriate to a professor,
to how to design a slide that didn't look
like the example we saw
a little bit earlier,
and I know we all make jokes
about that, but it's true.
I mean, you know, the number
one thing you're doing
as a graduate student or
someone in STEM or in any field
is communicating and being
able to communicate effectively
and clearly is just so invaluable.
And it's a bit of a softer skill
but one that I really credit STARS with,
you know, I think STARS for
me was really the first time
that, not only was I taught how to succeed
but I was also taught to never give up.
I think deep down inside,
I always knew I wanted to pursue STEM.
I didn't have parents that were scientists
or went to college for that matter,
but, you know, the STARS faculty members
really taught me to kind of pursue that
and never give up on that
and really seek mentors that
could help me along the way.
And, you know, that was
extremely invaluable for me.
So since that time, as a STARS student,
I, you know, I ended up doing STARS Summer
as well as STARS II.
One thing I'll mention
that someone actually said
a little earlier today,
is that in addition to the mentorship,
one key piece of the STARS Program
was the financial support that I received.
So, at the time when I was
doing STARS I and STARS II,
I had the opportunity to
go to multiple conferences
and present multiple posters and talks,
and it was because the STARS
program pay for my lodging
and pay for my registration.
I mean, there was absolutely no way
I was going to be able to take advantage
of those opportunities
if STARS wasn't financing
those opportunities for me.
And that was really, really invaluable,
even with STARS II.
You know, the opportunity
to get paid to do research,
to both further your
intellectual development
and your research skills,
while also generating the
income that perhaps you need
because you're sending money home
or you're paying for your
own books, or, you know,
paying for your own day-to-day expenses,
it's really something that,
you know, I sort of look back
and I think many of us feel the same way.
You know, I really credit
STARS with sort of saving me
in many ways and putting
me on the right track.
But since that time,
I went on to start an
MD/PhD program at Yale,
thankfully, to most of my STARS mentors,
including Dean Chang and, you know,
have recently started my own biotech
and just closed our series A.
So, you know, I say
that not to really brag,
but just to say that, you know,
I went from getting Cs in
chemistry and you know,
virtually feeling out of a university
to now achieving some level of success.
And it really wasn't
something I did on my own.
It was really something
I did because of STARS
and through the support
I received from STARS,
So, you know, I'm just really
grateful to the students
I've been able to mentor through STARS,
but especially to the
individuals who have mentored me.
I mean, it's really been
an invaluable process
and experience for myself.
And, you know, I'm just really grateful
to be here with you all
and to see that so many people
benefited from this program
and decided to give back
by being here today.
So thank you all
and thank you Dean Chang
for organizing all of this
and putting us all together.
- Thank you very much Elias
and thank you to all the
speakers in the morning session.